the thing is we've spoken about this on  the show on multiple occasions that you  put your child at every statistical  disadvantage when you choose to become a  single mother I'm choosing to become a  single one now hang on but you're  choosing to have to raise a child in a  household without a man okay so your  child is more likely to be homeless your  child is more likely to go to prison  your child is more likely to have mental  issues your child is more likely to be a  an angry Grapist he's more likely to be  in a gang she he or she  can children that come from single  parent households specifically single  mother households are subject to all of  those things okay  and it can range from 60 of the children  you need more detail to my story then to  ABS at the children  like the fact that you would choose that  I